GUEST SPEAKER 1: A
lights game, where
basically if you tap on the red
light, you increase your score.
And each time you tap correctly,
it keeps switching in between.
And so, the original
concept for this game
was a kind of a game sort of
like Guitar Hero or Dance Dance
Revolution, where you have the
music synced with the light.
So you're tapping
them in rhythm.
And if you get then in
rhythm and at the right time,
the right buttons, that's when
you get the highest score.
But we were having a lot
of issues with regards
to just getting this
hardware and software set up,
so we decided to throw it on
the stove for the project.
It's not my plain theory.
We could apply this very
easily to that type of project.
So basically what the
components we have here are,
we have capacitive sensors.
So basically just a wire
where you just touch it,
it just changes the
capacitance of the circuit
so you can just register that.
They're pretty receptive,
pretty receptive.
Lost the [INAUDIBLE] somewhere.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: And
they're in rainbow order.
You hit them in rainbow
order, so you have the ability
to project ahead.
You know it's going to go
here, here, here, here, here.
No problem.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: See, you
follow the orange one,
you see that one is
what becomes red next.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Oh,
you told them the--
[LAUGHTER]
--secret.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: And one of the
cool things that we realized
is that, upon making this,
that actually having LED set up
farther away from
the acrylic covering
actually makes the
squares seem brighter
because the light
kind of diffuses.
As opposed to being
right next to the acrylic
where you just see the LEDs.
But if you back
off, you actually
get a lot more illumination.
One of the cool lessons.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: We would love
to give a lot of credit to Tay.
He was the guy in our group who
made this acrylic with a laser
printer, and put the wood
so that each of the squares
were in their own places.
He just made this
beautiful set up.
Unfortunately, he's
not here today.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: Also a lot
of the soldering back here.
There's a lot of
soldering that's going on.
These are really cool.
Also, they sell LEDs.
These LEDs were actually one
series of LEDs down the strip.
So there's like 150
LEDs on a couple
of meters of this kind of a--
GUEST SPEAKER 5: A spool.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: On a spool.
And you can actually control
each one individually
with Arduino.
Just be careful not to
power up all of the,
because you'll actually
pass a lot of current
through your USB.
Probably damage
your USB Arduino.
One of the things that
we learned about wiring
and knowing how much
current's going through.
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
Luckily, we learned--
AUDIENCE: Are you going
to continue to USB, or?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: No,
we learned this one.
GUEST SPEAKER 5: Luckily Andrew
had the magic line of code
which allows you to just limit
the total amount of current
you're putting out.
So even if you ask it to
draw a ton of current,
you just dim LEDs.
GUEST SPEAKER 4: We were
actually warned about a minute
before we were going to try
it, so it saved a laptop
from being destroyed.
So it was a big lesson.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Anybody
want to have a try?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Well, firstly,
do you want to say anything?
GUEST SPEAKER 3: That was
about the right summary.
And we will maybe
attempt to continue
to add more features,
including timing
so you get more
points for ending it
in the rhythm with
lights or music.
We were originally going to
include some of the processing
code that the Arduino
team used last time
to make some lights
that flash and sync
with the beat of the music.
But due to technical
difficulties
with wiring, and
capacity, et cetera.
That's going to be
in a later version.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
so, that's our project.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned an
acrylic piece was printed.